ding-ding-ding-ding-ding Julian put tape
on my cup so that I don't know what
you're talking about
potato welcome to the Jen and Jillian
podcast where you talk about the Jen and
Jillian things among other things
look Matt guys things this podcast is
brought to you by Club W never shop for
wine again have fresh wine delivered
right to your door v Club W guys go to
club W calm slash Jenna and Julian to
get $20 off your first order right now
it's also brought to you by blue apron
get farm-fresh ingredients delivered
directly to your door guys everything is
deliver to your door now we live in 2016
there's everything delivered to your
door and these are some of the best
companies that do it blue apron delivers
farm-fresh ingredients to cook an entire
meal perfectly measured out for you
you select your meals online they ship
to your house go to blue apron comm /
Jenna Julian and get your first two
meals on us Wade thank you to our
sponsors more on those later Thank You
sponsors yeah our sponsors are basically
just like a perfect dinner little
sponsored by W and belabored sponsored
by dinner delivered to you our fresh
wine mo right it just reminds me of the
jerk bring us some new wine some fresh
wine this year
what is a new I didn't say new I said it
fresh because it's made directly nine
finesse it's not kind of this old wine
break it some fresh wine no bony that's
like one of my favorite would anyone
like that joke who smoked Martin anybody
like I read ways never just me um yeah
so this week on the podcasts I was
started fishing around I've seen other
youtubers read like their fan fictions
in the past and it's really something
more funny some of them are porn some
are like actual porn and I know that
some have existed of me but you know
it's not really something I do like I'm
on my channel or even like a vlog
channel like it's so it's so suitable
for a podcast I think it's pretty sit
here and read some fanfiction
so some of them are very old which you
know whatever they're wonderful
and I've read some of them and they're
hysterical but I wanted to read some
that also included Julian on the podcast
because it's the Jenna Julian podcast I
mean we could just read Jenna fanfiction
I'm fine either way
no these okay we did not read these
beforehand we read like you know the
first paragraph or so and some of them
most of them about us are just about us
like getting married or like yeah
there's a lot of pop the question ones
and so like that but they're really
sweet and I'm hoping maybe they don't
turn into porn but we we haven't read
them also with it my turn in the porn it
could but the point is is that we are
going to be sitting here reacting to
them as they happen yes we know we never
read these guys who skim through a few
of them very briefly but what's that one
I thought you went
it's called Jenna's Jenna Jenna miles
pregnant sorry I'm just looking through
them all right what are we starting with
pop I thought you said you wanted to
read pops when we pop first okay so do
you want to say what happened is or yeah
it's in what what on what web pattern
Wattpad what what what
dance what are ya are you doing I'm just
I'm just opening it up Jillian's there
you have it just trying to open it oh my
god there's so many parts I know okay
well here's the thing if we're getting
to the part like that's you can't read
maybe we'll move on but like we said we
haven't checked these so yeah we have we
don't know where they're gonna go
we don't know really who wrote them we
have like their user names but like
might be lit they might be porn mmm it
might be lit porn
oh this bone isn't by yeah all right so
let's get into the first one Shelly so
we're gonna repeal me write you redo
everything yeah some of them look like
they're written from it'll say like
Jenna and then I'm speaking and then
Julian so we're gonna read it that way
so this one is called pop it's gonna be
any and Julian pop or I guess in here it
says pop Jenna and Julian it's by user
Josh Lee and ex Julian yeah so the
description reads as follows
it's almost Jenna's 30th birthday and
she and Julian have been dating for a
while Jenna's hoping Julian will
the question and they both can't wait to
start a family and pop out some babies
but things might not be turning out how
they planned oh okay
so shall we shall we get into the let's
do it let's read pop all right I'll read
the first one well because you're my
spective Chapter one wedding wishes
Jenna I'm gonna read it like [ __ ] um
cereal you're gonna try to be like no
not really
okay Jenna Sunday morning I wake up and
immediately look over it Julian my
wonderful boyfriend he's still asleep so
I grab my phone and check Twitter people
are already tweeting at me birthday
wishes but my birthday is not for three
days it's a big birthday I'm turning 30
it's true I will be turning 30 a normal
woman would probably probably be super
sad or scared to turn 30 but I'm excited
I've got one more year of life
experience and one more year of
happiness under my belt and it means I
get to live another great year of my
life
sounds like you I'm also hoping this
will be the year Julie and I get married
whoo I'm unplugging is that Moe fuse
making my phone crazy I used to not
really love the idea of marriage I used
to not really see the point I still like
the idea of committing to someone for
life and not needing a certificate or a
reign to do it but I'm so in love with
Julian and I know he feels the same as
me you know that's like are you is this
you did you write this right on you it's
yeah it's not so much about needing a
wedding to prove our love it's about
wanting to spend forever with Julian and
wanting to be able to call Julian my
husband and showing the world how in
love we are maybe it doesn't make sense
but I can't fully explain why I want to
marry Julian so badly I just do
maybe I've always liked the idea of a
wedding but I've never liked the idea of
a wedding with any of my past boyfriends
I'm just really excited for my 30th year
I already feel like it holds good things
end of chapter one
okay chapter two the ring sir Sunday
morning I wake up and look next to me
jenna is sitting up in bed on Twitter
her hair's in a messy side bun and she
doesn't have any makeup on she looks
gorgeous hey Julian she soon as
realizing that I'm awake i otter I reply
and kiss her this is like it's scarily
accurate though like the language
everything um do you want to do anything
today she asks I don't know I want to
have a lazy day today I might just go to
the gym I lie I'm not gonna go to the
gym I'm gonna go to the jeweler and pick
up a birthday present for Jenna
a really big birthday present an
engagement ring oh my god later on
Sunday afternoon bye babe I cause I walk
out the door to go to the gym as I got
in the car I pulled out vlog II I've
been vlogging as I planned the proposal
and get everything together but not
putting the clips in the vlogs I'll
include them in the engagement video hey
guys it's September 12
three days before Jenna's birthday so
I'm in the car right now driving to the
jeweler to pick up Jenna's ring as you
guys already know I had a design but
today's a day I actually get it I get to
the jeweler and walk inside I tell the
lady at the name at the desk my name oh
yes Julia no go get your ring
she says cheerfully I can't believe I'm
proposing in three days I'm so nervous
the woman comes back with a ring box and
introduces herself as Lisa so were you
proposing to Lisa asks she gets the
papers I have to sign her name is Jenna
I say what a pretty name how long have
you two been together yes almost four
years I respond okay Lisa says yeah it's
been a while but it's been the best four
years of my life I tell her that was
cheesy but I don't care it's completely
true oh then it says hope you like it so
far
okay chapter three is called oh my god
oh my
airman okay Jena Monday Julien is
hanging out with Josh and Arnold today
God so I'm just relaxing with the dogs
today's Monday and Wednesday is my
birthday
of course my [ __ ] birthday's on a
Wednesday they look that up I don't know
oh my god doesn't matter but it feels
like it always is okay I want to be able
to relax on my actual birthday so I
decided to film today and edit tomorrow
good oh good Gianna that's smart
thinking okay work I go upstairs to put
on makeup and do my hair which is
turquoise at the top and fades it to
pink at the bottom right now it's quite
a look once I've done I go downstairs
and set up the shot it's going to be 30
things I've learned in 30 years it looks
like the same one okay so I set up the
camera and lights in front of a wall in
our living room and move a chair there
okay guys so today is my birthday well
it's not right now but when it's right
now for you it's not right now for me
right now it's my birthday
it's like [ __ ] time-travel my god I
say to start the video so since it's my
birthday I wanted to do a video where
suddenly I feel nauseous
I run to the bathroom and puke that's so
weird why did I vomit I didn't eat
anything weird and I almost never get
stuff ik bugs
I feel better though so I filmed the
rest of my video and everything goes
smoothly Tuesday morning I wake up and
head to the bathroom immediately my
period is supposed to start today and
when it comes it's super heavy the first
day this is graphic so I always wear a
tampon skip this part is supposed to
come I pause it and it's totally white
not a drop of blood on it that's strange
oh it'll probably come later today
though so I put a new tampon in I don't
think you're supposed to do that I don't
think you're supposed to put tampons in
if you don't have your period I was just
saying you could google it I don't know
I'm just a cover
okay just as I get up to push my hands I
feel a wave of nausea I vomited to the
toilet this is so weird I vomited twice
the past few days and my period is late
oh my god I think I'm pregnant
chapter 4 is also used so oh okay
chapter 4 it's a long one Julian is
editing the blog from the weekend and
yesterday so I tell him I'm gonna run to
Target to pick the picks and things up
before I go to Target I Drive to
Walgreens and look for a pregnancy test
the store is pretty much empty once I
find the right aisle I grab three tests
I walk up to the cashier and awkwardly
hand her the tests she's a cute old
woman who looks about 70 please don't
say anything please don't say anything
I'm mentally Begg so you think you might
be pregnant she asks sweetly
well [ __ ] um yeah I say awkwardly well
you don't seem too excited she says it's
just not the right time I reply
sweetheart let me tell you something if
you go through life looking for the
perfect time to have kids you're never
gonna have any there will always be
something you're not married you're busy
with your job money's tight you have to
care for your parents by the time you
feel ready to have kids your time might
be up if you're pregnant just know that
everything will be okay now's as good a
time as any she tells me then she hands
me my bag thanks so much I tell her as I
walk out congratulations she calls after
me with a sweet smile wait like way to
jinx it lady Yeah right I get in the car
and drive to Target all I could think
about is what the lady at Walgreens said
maybe this is a good thing I started to
imagine Julian holding our little baby
and I pictured the dogs licking him or
her I think about him as a toddler
dancing around the house I think about
reading them bedtime stories I imagine
Julian and I tried to censor ourselves
around them and laughing when our kids
say [ __ ] because they say it too often
suddenly I'm crying I'm overcome with
happiness and excitement if I am
pregnant it would be amazing I dry my
tears and walk into target the first
place I go is the
through him luckily there's no line so I
go in and find a stall and pull my first
test out I pee on it and then I set it
up on the toilet on top of the toilet I
have to wait two minutes to see if I'm
pregnant
so I pee on the second test and set that
down I don't really have any pee left so
I say the third test for later I checked
my phone to see what time it is
207 at 209 I can look at the tests I
checked my phone to pass the time and I
see the Julian texted me it was with a
picture of him in a peach shirt she's
been here with peach in his shirt each
in his shirt she's been here for an hour
and she won't leave the text read oh my
heart I text back oh my heart literally
the things I would text you about you
know Julian is so caring and sweet he'd
make a great dad I look at the clock of
my phone and it says 209 oh my god holy
[ __ ] it's not of truth what stocked it I
pick up the first test it only has one
line on it which means not pregnant I
don't know how to feel relieved sad
happy disappointed wait
there's a very faint second line oh my
god I look at the second one there's two
definite lines I'm pregnant just an hour
ago I would be devastated but now I am
so incredibly happy I can't believe it
Oh quickly point out that this is really
well-written yeah so there's a little
back and forth in this chapter chapter 5
Julian's plan okay Tuesday night Jenna
comes home from Target and looks super
happy I can't believe I'm gonna pop the
question tomorrow I'm so excited
hey otter I say to her hi babe she
replies I'm sitting on the couch so she
comes and snuggles up next to me are you
excited for your birthday I asked her
yeah she says I can't wait for the next
year of my life good I respond and kiss
her on her forehead I was more asking
about the day rather than the year but
that's okay then I go I guess I'm laying
there cuddled up next to Julian and
excited to tell him I'm pregnant
but I want to make it special I don't
just want to come out and say it I rest
my head on his chest and I'm so grateful
for him I love you so much otter
Oh in a baby but I love you so much
otter
I love you too otter Julian replies I
can't wait to grow with you
oh I exclaimed Julian is the sweetest
person ever I kiss him passionately and
I never want to stop Julian is my world
and I know he'll support me through
anything and everything especially the
baby he makes me so happy happier than
I've ever felt before we lay there
talking for an eternity
and Jenna falls asleep on my chest I
look down at her 24 hours from now
she'll be my fiancee
at least I hope she will be oh I keep
replaying the advice Josh journal gave
me in my head don't let your nerves get
to you or get in the way of telling her
how much she means to you don't
overthink it whatever happens will be
perfect whether it's what you plan or
not I went over the plan again in my
head tomorrow morning I'm going to get
up early and decorate the house for her
birthday then I'm gonna go the
restaurant and drop off my camera so
they can hide it somewhere that'll
shower table around lunchtime I'll give
Jenna her present simple gold necklace
with an auto charm then I'll give her
the first clue of her scavenger hunt
Katherine will spend the afternoon
driving around La to find places in the
scalp to have a scavenger hunt leads to
the last clue will take us to the fancy
restaurant what's with it I don't know
about that it's really quick as romantic
as fancy restaurants can be there's like
at least 10 things more romantic that
Jenna would pick other than a fancy
restaurant like going to fancy
restaurants she likes me hosts Nate's
delivery yeah blue apron
Julian like every year he's like can I
take you out today if your birthday I'm
like can you can we like order food and
eat it here just like so desperately
want to like wine and dine her and like
take her out to a nice dinner and get
dressed up and but that's the part I
hate I hate all of that
I like wining and dining but I like
doing it in my professional to get out
of your balance to do it it's special to
do it out in public in a nice dimly lit
romantic little corner booth mm-hmm
while someone pours your wine for you no
no okay
okay once we're there I'm just going to
do it we'll be sitting there chatting
having a great dinner and I'll just get
down on one knee and hopefully
everything will go smoothly we'll just
have to wait and see this kind of filler
chapter oops
also I can't stop writing this fanfic
expect more tonight LOL so some this has
some decent numbers on it right people
read it yeah uh like 200 or something
solid you guys were to go check it out
yeah okay chapter six birthday morning
Oh
the first thing I think of when I wake
up this morning is telling Julian I'm
pregnant I wanted to think of a creative
way to tell him but I can't wait any
longer I don't like keeping secrets from
him even if they're good things I roll
over to nudge Julian awake but he's not
there I get out of bed and walk
downstairs to look for him but he's
nowhere all this is so real high school
I I look if I'm always not checking find
friends and I'm like always at dejection
where are you going Russell I go back to
our bedroom to get my phone so I can
call him when I pick up my phone I see I
have a text from Julian it said I'll be
back in a bit
go back to bed honor PS happy birthday
he knew I'd be looking for him I try to
go back to sleep I look down on my
stomach there's a baby in there I think
to myself I pull my shirt up my little
miracles in there this is so surreal I
fall asleep again and the next thing I
know Julian is joseline me awake that's
exactly what happens
jostling toss you hours later data
Julian calls from the kitchen make you
lunch come in here think of what why are
you keep cooking for me I walk in
holding marbles I need to tell Julian
I'm pregnant
now I can't wait any longer Julian I am
eating lunch Julian says in a baby voice
cutting me off by accident that looks
delicious I tell him I sit down and
Julian starts talking somehow we
mentioned kids I can't wait to have kids
one day you'll be such a great mom
Julian says you'll be a wonderful dad I
tell him now's my chance
actually we won't have to wait very long
to be parent parents I'm pregnant I
should say but I don't I get too scared
I know I'm excited but
might not be ready Jenna it's time for
your present Julian says as he grabs a
box from the counter odd or what is it I
asked in a baby voice as I rip apart the
wrapping paper hello
Julian replies matching my voice after
all the wrapping paper is gone I see
that it's a jewelry box Julian I exclaim
as I open it I gasped oh my god honor
it's gorgeous I love it it's a golden
otter charm on a delicate gold chain
where did you get this it's perfect I
explain Julian tells me where he got it
and then kisses me do you like it oh
that's you yeah okay yes yes I love it
babe I couldn't have asked for a better
gift I gentleman okay well I have
something else for you he says really
honor oh my god
he pulls our little slip of paper it's a
clue to a scavenger hunt is this a
scavenger hunt yes go get ready we're
gonna be gone all afternoon evening
tells me oh it's getting good good
chapter seven is getting yeah it's
getting late I'm glad that this isn't
like porn no I like it it's like it's
very uh well the thing is it's like you
know what's interesting is it's like a
the writing of fairy tale you know about
two people that they know and they enjoy
watching but the craziest part is that
like it's so true to life like this is
not fanfiction it feels like real like
you know even if it's not happening it
feels like every little detail can
really be real for real um it's almost
trippy but Wednesday night we've
wandered around the city for about four
hours for Jenna's birthday scavenger
hunt the clue run right now is leading
us to the dog park where Jenna's last
clue will be waiting we pull up to the
dog park and Jenna sees a slip of paper
that looks like the rest of our clues
I feel pretty proud of this idea as
jenna gets out of the car to grab it not
to toot my own horn but I think this was
a really good idea Jenny got back into
the car and studies the clue
wait Julian she exclaims oh we gonna
where I think we're going I not your
favorite fancy restaurant doesn't exist
I tell her in the baby voice your
favorite fancy restaurant I saw
everybody boys we drive there and I try
as hard as I can hide how nervous I feel
Julian what does real I got that covered
I respond then I reached back to the
backseat and handed her makeup case you
could do this on the way ah did not see
my makeup tutorial in the car
something like that if only it was that
smooth not you the first night rose as
soon as no as soon as we get there the
hostess knows who we are she tells Jonas
she is a dress for her and brings her a
dress that I dropped up okay Jenna runs
into the bathroom two chains and I tell
her I'll wait on the bench till she's
ready I'm so nervous I feel like I could
vomit
we're both vomiting well I feel like I
could mom I've already told the hostess
Britney my plans so she knows what's
going on
are you nervous Britney asks nervous is
an understatement
I say with this I don't be it's obvious
that you and Jenna have a great
relationship and you're so you're both
so in love with each other everything
will go just how it shows Britney for
sure Britney said Wow Britney knows us
pretty well right thanks for that
Britney I reply she made me feel much
better
no problem she walks back to her podium
just as Jenna walks out of the bathroom
you look beautiful I tell her I'm syan
you said you look pretty handsome huh
you look pretty handsome yourself thank
you I needed you to read that she
responds Britney leads us to our table
we get settle I'm so nervous throughout
the whole meal that I can barely eat wow
that must mean I am nervous yeah the
[ __ ] right he's like oh I like flour
Tuesday no like yeah I feel pretty
nervous
there's like no scenario which you'd be
too nervous see yeah that's happened no
I finally build up the courage to do it
Jenna
I am so insanely glad I met you I tell
her
ah Julie no really you make me so happy
the kind of happy words cannot explain
the past three and a half years have
honestly been the best years of my life
and I can't wait to spend the rest of my
years with you
you too I tell Jenna then I get down on
one knee I love you so so so so much
Jenna Colmar will you marry me she
definitely is gonna say no I'm just
kidding okay chapter 8 I ruined every
chapter eight hell no I'm totally
kidding
good Wednesday night I love you so so so
much identical Mari will you marry me
Julianne ass I'm in tears oh my god yes
of course honor I love you Julian says
the sea slides the ring on my finger he
stands up and I kiss him he makes me so
incredibly happy I feel like our kiss
last for an eternity but it's still not
long enough I can't stop staring at my
ring it's a diamond-encrusted band with
a giant oval diamond in the center you
like your honor
I love Julian it's gorgeous and i assure
him we sit at the table just staring at
each other lovingly it's not awkward at
all it's wonderful we don't have to
speak to know how the other is feeling
we'd say you we like just got to the
table and you propose I think I did it
before apps huh yeah well alright well
better get some [ __ ] in Julian's game
now I'm hungry yeah I still can't get
over the fact that Julian just proposed
um my bed Julian we're engaged I
exclaims I know you're my fiancee she
replies movie once's I respond in a
weird accent we eventually leave the
restaurant to go somewhere else for
dessert we're walking to the dessert
place which is a few blocks away and all
I can think about is the baby I'm so
ridiculously happy to be engaged but I
need to tell Julian I'm pregnant
hey yatta I start yeah he says you know
how we were talking about how we can't
wait to have a kid
I say Julian nods confused well um don't
chicken out tell myself uh it looks like
we won't have to wait much longer
I tell him wait what Julian almost
completely stopped walking and pregnant
I managed to squeeze out oh my god are
you serious Julian exclaims I'm dead
serious I stayed with the knot oh is
that a happy oh my god or a disappointed
oh my god I asked nervously my heart
sinks how could this happen
we just got engaged and I ruined our
special night how can I ruin okay I
can't believe I was so stupid this was
supposed to be the best night of our
lives but I just burden Julian with
insane news I'm trying to hold back
tears
honestly why was I even excited I'm not
ready to be a mom and Julian's not ready
to be a dad I start bawling sure what's
wrong Julian s I'm so sorry I sobs no
don't be sorry he tells me I can't not
be sorry why not today was supposed to
be the best day of our lives you put so
much time and effort into today and I
just ruined it I tell him wiping my
tears as more tears flow alright next
chapter don't be sorry chapter nine
Jenna Jenna stop come here I sit her
down at one of the empty tables from a
closeout to our restaurants we don't
have to keep walking I grabbed her with
love my hands Jenna you didn't ruin
anything I say she won't even look at me
she's too ashamed of herself look at me
got me yoga that's what it's nice to
peach when she does something naughty
she looks a look at me to me this just
came even like Jenna look at me I say
gently pushing her chin up there's
nothing to be sorry for I'm just as
responsible for the baby as you are we
made this baby together obviously I
wasn't expecting this and it's a big
shock she lets out a song
yeah I kiss your hand obviously this is
a surprise but I'm beyond excited I'm
not going to lie to you I would never
she pull cheap okay so you cut me off
she pulls one of my hands away to wipe
her tears look Jenna having a baby is a
lot of work it's tiring it's expensive
it's stressful but it's also super
wonderful and it's something we both
really want I know we weren't planning
on this but it'll be amazing I promise
you as long as I have a say I'll make it
I'll make the world perfect for you I
tell her I'm really really excited to be
a dad I say well that is strange to
think about I'm gonna be a dad I'm gonna
have a little baby Jenna and I are gonna
be parents Jenna sighs Thank You Julian
for making me feel better and thank you
for making today amazing and just for
being who you are I love you so much she
says it's all watch love you more I
whisper I kiss her well I may gather
after a while Jenna breaks the kiss I
think it's illegal to be sitting in the
outside part of this restaurant when
it's closed she tells me let's get out
of here then Fi
I grabbed her hand and start leaning her
way to the dessert place Julian Jenna
ass sweetly yes my love do we have to
get dessert or can we just go home no
let's go home on that's so real okay she
says I know there's literally like two
people reading this but I really hope to
people are enjoying it so alright next
chapter no more tears chapter 10 okay
we're laying on a couch cuddling Lea I
like this this is this is fun yeah when
Julian asked me how long did you know
you were pregnant
oh sorry Zuri well Jerry pregnant I took
two pregnancy tests yesterday I tell him
okay Julian says as he pulls my shirt up
to reveal my stomach look Thanks yeah
yeah there's a little baby otter and now
he says in a baby voice oh I squeal my
heart we sit there talking about our
future about our wedding and about our
kid
it's normal for us we talked about our
future all the time this time is
different from the rest though this time
we know things will happen soon I think
about it and I start crying 10 are you
ok
Julien asked me yes I'm fine these are
happy tears I tell them my hormones are
insane ok I just want to make sure you
were happy I actually was really excited
I was just scared you wouldn't be but
now that I know you're excited I can be
excited I tell them good he replies we
cuddle more and watch them YouTube and
then I tells Julian how exhausted I am
today is pretty exhausting day Julian
says you're engaged and pregnant I laugh
very true I'm so [ __ ] engaged in
[ __ ] pregnant did you have a good
birthday OTT I've had the best birthday
ever I tell him before I know it I'm
asleep and Julian's chest that's I like
honestly if I'm ever [ __ ] pregnant
I'm just gonna say that all the time
I'm still [ __ ] pregnant I like the
juxtaposition of trying stuff
outrageously inappropriate yell I'm so
[ __ ] pregnant
ok um Thursday I get up this morning and
I promise myself
I won't cry today happy tears or sad
tears it won't happen I've cried enough
in the past few days to last me months I
call my doctor and make a pregnancy
appointment for Monday I realized that
with all the events of yesterday I never
uploaded my weekly video oh good god I
broke my [ __ ] oh my Oh what well it's
not Thursday so it's normal mom but I
think I should make a different video
today I go into the kitchen to find
Julian sitting at the table morning baby
he said in his baby voice good morning
to you sir I reply the same voice okay I
want to make a new sexual Wednesday
video I want to tell my internet friends
we're engaged we be in it true how about
about an hour later we're all set to
film hi guys so I had a super mushy
thirty things I've learned in 30 years
video but I decide
that that wasn't mushy enough so Julie
and I have a big surprise for you I say
I count down from three you ready
one oh wait three two one oh did you
okay sorry that's that's exactly what
they wrote I'm kidding no we basically
tell the whole story of our engagement
I'll insert the clips the Julian blog
too when I edit the video at the end of
the video I address my old video about
my thoughts on marriage I say how my
views have shifted I say that I still
love the idea of not needing a ring or a
dress to make you commit but I also say
that I love the idea of what a wedding
is a day dedicated to your love that you
get to share with family and friends
where you get to focus on how much you
love the person you're marrying I keep
accidentally mentioning the baby but
I'll have to cut out every part
involving me being pregnant we don't
want to tell the world we're expecting
until we tell all of our family and
friends now that I think about it
telling our family and friends will be
really fun I can't wait oh that was it
author's note all right yomaira thousand
yeah hi so I just wanted to say that if
this whole fanfic actually took place
around Janus 30th birthday it might be a
little too early for Julian to propose
as much as I want them to get engaged
ASAP I think Julie might wait a few
years to pop the question
hahaha pop because the fan base pop okay
I'll stop but the reason why I'm keeping
it her 30th birthday is because I think
it's being such a big birthday adds to
the plot and besides it's fan fiction a
girl can't dream can't she
laughing oh gee uh that was really nice
no no that was uh it is I'm not familiar
with the fiction because I've only heard
and read a little little bit of it but
it's it was very nice
it was very nice it was it was very
sweet and I'm glad that it wasn't like
straight-up porn
cuz I would stop [ __ ] I would have to
stop reading it I'd be laughing too hard
yeah yeah I mean I I wouldn't be the
type of person to like come up with a
glass of wine and read some fanfiction
but if I did I would definitely get some
Club W because then I wouldn't have to
get out of that Club W can finally relax
guys because you'll never have to worry
about being wine free again Club W is a
revolutionary new wine club that sends
wine directly to your door
saving you all those trips to the
grocery store not only does Club W send
you wine guys they send you the wine
that you will love drinking so you
basically fill out an easy six question
quiz it figures out your palate and then
they pick bottles that are perfectly
selected for that palate of yours they
work directly with vineyards to cut out
the middleman guys it's it's incredibly
tasty wine like I'm telling you we've
had bottle after bottle and it is just
top-notch stuff they even offer a risk
free guarantee or sorry a no risk
guarantee that you'll love what they
send you they guarantee it guys go to
club w.com
slash Jenna and Julianne there is an end
in there so it's Club W calm slash Jenna
and Julianne and you get 20 bucks off
your first order right now and use that
URL guys it gets even better I know you
all hate paying for shipping so to Club
W comm /n Julianne and they will pay for
shipping from bottles our owners of
bottles with four or more in it so and
trust me you'll run through those
bottles so nothing worth it
guys check that out go to club W calm
slash Jenna and Julianne and get on your
way to some wonderful wine brought to
your door like you're a king or a queen
they just bring the wine do don't leave
me my wine me my wine make sure it's
something my mouth will enjoy box of
bottles one book sometimes guys our
other sponsor this week is blue apron
blue apron is a similar service but it's
for food ingredients it's farm-fresh
ingredients they send you so it's
similar to club W but you basically you
know choose your preferences in food on
the website on your club or on your blue
apron profile and you know say you're
cutting back on red meat right you don't
eat that much red meat you're able to
put that in so people can see who are
putting together your box of fresh
ingredients that you're not eating red
meat right now so they will lower your
intake
that is very customizable meals guys
that's exactly to what you want another
interesting thing is they comes with two
forms in the Box one is an instruction
form or you can read exactly how you're
supposed to cook the meal it's a recipe
it's instructions and it makes so it's
like foolproof anything that you don't
[ __ ] up and you can keep it the other
thing is it's a it's a leaflet basically
it's called from the farm in it and it
shows you where the farms are of each of
the ingredients in the box which is very
cool because it shows you the proof of
how fresh all the ingredients are and
not that you need it because it tastes
incredible you can also dictate when
your weekly box arrives so say you get
out of work like late you can have it
delivered a little later so it's not
sitting there all day and the day of
them and the day of the week obviously
so you know it's wonderful we've had
we've had blue apron before it it's just
so delicious so if you guys want to try
it you go to blue apron dot-com slash
Jenna Julianne that's blue apron dot-com
slash Jenna Julianne you get first two
meals on us if you missed any of the
links they're always in the description
thank you to our sponsors thank you
sponsors oh man I found another one that
looks good I found a couple one of them
I found has mature content mmm do we
want to go there I don't know but this
this one I found you get kidnapped oh I
like that do I fight my way out mmm
oh my god okay I read the bottom line
alright I'll read the first chapter of
this don't you get out of this yes the
dough bath back up to the top I was just
kidding yes and I started reading this
to you yeah okay just because I saw the
bottom and now I'm trying not to laugh
this is called J and J troubles it's by
chase Elliott um on Wattpad shhh are you
ready should I get it you can but I want
to start reading you there girl my
friend says Jenna ending her newest
video all right now what peach karmic
marbles she says talking to her dogs
three of them just look at her jenna
gets up from her chair and heads to the
living room to watch a movie as soon as
she should sits down her phone rings
it's a random number so
she doesn't answer her phone keeps
ringing and ringing and ringing finally
she answers it what the hell do you want
she shouts Jenna it's me Julian he's at
whispering Jenna it's me Jillian he says
whispering Julian had left to go to the
store to get more kale I'm in some
trouble I was kidnapped and I need your
help
he says so whispering are you serious
how did that sleep never mind what do
you need me to do she replies I need you
to not call the police and the phone
call ends
Genisys they're frightened thinking this
might be a prank but she knows Julian
sounded serious
she runs upstairs and packs a week worth
of stuff and a decent amount of cash she
takes the dogs to her mom's house and
lies to her mom saying Julian her going
on vacay okay Jenna rents the car and
takes off driving to Julian's brother
house Marlin is a hacker and compiling
is a hacker inconel yeah Wow we after to
I'd get I'm so into this I'm sweating I
wanna come home how I find it when I
search for well I already told you the
name well tell me again it's called J
and J troubles no I'm just look up J no
not like that J the word aunt and then
Jett chapter 2 hey Jenna says Marlin hey
Marlon here's the phone number he called
from says Jenna Marlin grabs the phone
and runs to his computer within five
seconds he knew where Julian called from
Nevada Marlin shops
I like your Marlin Nevada that's pretty
close can you tell what part Jenna asks
yeah Vegas Farland says let's go Marlin
packs a bag quick and they take Jenna's
car once they get to Vegas they realize
it's going to be even harder than they
thought to find the phone Julian use
they split up and go to every place they
can think of asking people that they've
seen a man with Julian's description no
luxe as Marlon as they
back to the car me it screams likey that
me let me eat screech someone pulls into
the parking lot and slams into Jenna's
car we don't have time like somebody
hits your car using that I'm making tea
move the [ __ ] out of my parts car and I
yell we don't have time for this Jenna
screams what the hell are we gonna do
now says Marlon I don't have the money
for a new car and we don't have time so
I have no clue replies Jenna so they get
the stuff out of the car ding Jenna gets
an idea kai read chapter 3 good there's
a weird that I've done their dinner
Jenna walks into a bar with the hottest
outfit she's fine while marlin waits for
her at the casino next door
Jenna sits down next to a guy he's a
little older than she is but she picked
you to sit next to wisely no fraud well
hello there ganja's she says some
innocent was that a good judge the man
next nevermind I'm sorry well hello
there gorgeous says the man aye sir hey
hot stuff Jenna says parting with him he
buys her a drink
she makes sure he doesn't leave to use
the restroom they chat for about 20
minutes right when he was about to get
up to go Jenna interrupts him why where
are you staying at the hotel down the
street why he replies oh wait sorry he
responds the hotel down the street what
he replies let's go there she says and
then winks oh I'm trying to pick me up a
man he smiles and says it's for y'all
girl McDonough she grabs his tie and
drags him out the door
oh he follows her and I just actually I
went to the next chapter he he follows
her follows and leads him to the car he
smirks at her as he puts the keys in the
ignition
once they get to the okay still late
Nash's he says his keys on a dresser in
the bedroom and heads to the bathroom
Jenny begins to unbutton her table wait
for me he says as soon as he closes the
door Jenna grabs his keys and quietly
sneaks out the door she calls Marlon
once she is on the way
on my way Jenna says she pulls up to the
curb at the casino and Marlon jumps in
oh my god and they are off to who knows
wait so I just [ __ ] hustled
guy for his car yeah [ __ ] dude you need
to find me is that am I not worth a
stolen car I would commit grand theft
auto humor racing
oh my yeah I just pretended to go sleep
with that guy's Jack his car like that's
next-level [ __ ] chapter four ring ring
ring Jenna answers the phone right away
it's Julian I think I'm gonna text it
I'm in Texas at a hotel I heard someone
say we will be here for a few hours I
love you Julian whispers I love you too
Jenna starts crying when the phone
starts beeping they stopped at a gas
station so Marlin contracted Monica this
is a Marlin bad thing stop Jenna screams
come on slams on the brakes
Jenna gets out of the car she walked
over a familiar item vlog II what is it
my aunt asked it's Julian's camera she
turns on goes to the gallery there was a
video on it
Julian probably evolved vlogging while
getting kale Jenna I love how they keep
reiterating that I was buying kale
Jenna's eyes began to tear up she
presses play what happens in the video
took her by surprise
Jenna's sadness goes away and turns the
hanger they now know who's the kidnapper
that red lipstick went [ __ ] ain't going
to get far oh it's a lady that napped
you enough oh my god oh my god don't
mean I'd you're gonna ruin it okay I
already saw who was in the video Marlon
Astro second time Jennifer zoned out
thinking of revenge
Marlon pokes Jenna what Jenna shouts
sorry Marlon it's Miranda she take your
tone are we going Marlin s well Miranda
is on tour so I'll check and see where
her next show is Jenna says issues types
info and on Google a few minutes a few
moments later Jenna screams it scares
Marlin so he slams on the brakes jerking
them what the [ __ ] man shouts or w2e
what dubby dubby kind of man
chose her next show is in New York at
7:30 tonight that's across the country
Jenna says angrily will they be able to
make it oh god I'm sorry
I'm sorry um chapter 7 as Marlon drop
sighs Marone drives they think of a plan
to get to New York fast as they drive
they enter into a desert like place wait
so just to clarify
Miranda Kidd Miranda sings kidnaps
Julian and I think when you yelled what
when mom was bothering you I think it
was meant to be read in Miranda voice oh
wait done leader like that red lips and
[ __ ] ain't getting partners like
Miranda Marlins of hackers let's not be
he's not a good driver you keep slamming
on the brakes about a mile ahead of them
there's this big setup with cameras cars
and bodyguards hey pull over there Jenna
says she gets out of the car and is
immediately shot by a bodyguard
excuse me you can't be the bodyguard
stop stop talking jenna is still
dressing out but she warded the bar she
rolls her eyes suddenly she sees pitbull
and JLo
well yes I can can't you tell him in the
music video genesis' sassy this sassily
award sassily
yeah mmm Cecily sorry miss the guard
says and moves out of the way Jenna
flips her hair and calls from well let's
go Marlon I need my bodyguard for this
shindig mom'll be a good bodyguard
mom flexes and follow he's flexing with
his hacker backpack on pitbull is
drinking water and waiting for the next
scene JLo is dancing and singing Janet a
triple on the shoulder hey Miami no
mommy he said it looked like Miami okay
Gracie three or five feet or more wide
hey mami CUDA okay so that's a nice s to
you he remembers her from the fire ball
music video that's accurate true didn't
Jenna realizes that because he's so rich
he must have a private jet he can hustle
pitbull for his Jaden looks like it
um hey Kiki do me a favor Jenna asked he
pulls her aside and Jenna explains their
situation of course mommy as long as
you're in this video with me I get you
on a plane right away
Jenna agrees puts on the outfit
they shot the scene and the plane is
called it lands two miles from the video
shoot Jenna says goodbye to pitbull and
thanks him they jump in the stolen car
and drive out to the plane the flight
attendant welcomes them aboard and
they're off to New York oh my god so you
are not [ __ ] cool like that yo
because you mommy though MA mommy
Chapter II they land in New York around
6:30 they have an hour and a half to
find Julian before the show starts
Jenna searches up the venue while Marlin
calls a taxi over Jenna gives the taxi
driver the address and tells them they
need to hurry they end up getting stuck
in traffic due to everyone going to
Miranda show so funny I love this Jenna
looks at the time 7:12 shoot how far is
it from here to the address Jonas I
don't know less than a mile a couple
blocks Jenna looks at Marlon and he nods
Jenna hands the taxi driver $35 and says
thank you
Marlon did Jenna jump out of the car and
follow the directions on Jenna's phone
they run and run and run and run 7:20
will they make it
chapter 9 oh my god holy crap Jenna says
stopping in front of the venue from
miranda show she's breathing heavily
Marlon is to the clock red 727 let's go
Marlon Genesis walking back to the built
to the back of the building
Jenna sees Miranda's tour bus Jenna
looks at Mullen and puts her fingers to
her lips like hell I don't know like
maybe I'm sure okay good they crash down
a tiptoe to the bus right when they get
to the side of the bus they hear Miranda
inside and run but behind the bus
Miranda Rachel Josh walk off the bus and
into the building to begins to walk over
to the door but the bus begins to move
Marlon grabs a ladder on the back of the
bus and grabs Jenna's arm they climb to
the top of the bus Modelling rips off
off the fire escape
oh we got it because you know he's super
muscular that's what it says does
because says that they quietly hop in
after he rips off the fire escape I'm
telling you this is a Marlin Finn it's a
Marlin fan fiction there's so many girls
out there that love Marley they call him
the ginger a Channing Tatum like every
time he's involved you're Tatum ginger
Tatum Channing ginger Jenna looks around
where is he
she whispers and chapter chapter 10
Jenna turns around and there's Julianne
tied up with duct tape on his mouth
Jenna runs over and slowly pulls off the
duct tape trying to hug him and they
begin to kiss get a room Marlin says
Mike he just he has lines roll a car
would be ripped off the fire escape yeah
ripped off the fire escape like got on a
private plane flew to you and then
watches me kiss you goes get a room he's
literally James Bond yeah true Jenna
smiles at him what the [ __ ] are you
wearing Julianne us pitbull video how do
we get out of here is s like oh I'm like
oh that's gonna pay I got it Marlin
finds a knife and cuts off the rope
well Miranda's bus driver is a hired guy
in your dress like that
so Julian says Jenna glares at him she
opens the door but when she does it's
not what she expected oh my god Chapter
eleven well he Lulu Miranda is standing
there with her hands on her hips
I seem ex BAE's here to see human Jenna
Claire's at Miranda and she's just in
porn channel except Miranda why did you
kidnap my BAE she says well I needed
more bathe in Julian was only one left
his man bun is fury oh my god that's
what she says his main bun is furry and
I like it
Marlin holds up the knife that's no
reason to steal my brother he just
threads with a knife he says well back
off heater Josh walks onto the bus
let's go everyone is is everyone wait
what Miranda kidnapped Julian and we
tracked her Jack down Jenna says
suddenly the flash of blue and
red lights are seen to policemen's climb
onto the bus and one handcuffs Miranda
you can't you can't do these she screams
bang bang bang everyone turns around to
see the closet doorknob jingle Julian
Julian opens the door and comes out and
out comes clean what everyone yells the
other policeman speaks up the Miranda we
just took off the bus was a crazed fan
pretending to be Miranda Josh runs over
to Colleen and takes the tape off her
mouth
Marlon cuts the rope OMG she screams
Josh begins to kiss her again
Chad ruther Jim that's great what a
twist
what a [ __ ] twist chapter 13 Miranda
had her show and just two hours just two
hours later John has changed into
appropriate clothes they all stayed and
watched the show after they said goodbye
Jenna Julian and Marlon got back on pit
bulls plane thanks little bro Julian
said hugging Marlon how long do we get
to the valley ask the pilot before they
took off about 12 hours that's really
funny
okay saying Jenna said thank you and
went to her seat so how did you find me
I want to hear the whole story Julian
said can't we wait till we get home Jen
asked fine do you still have that
costume from pitbulls video Julia yeah
why is Joe in the puzzled look Julian
winked at her
and led you into the bedroom in the back
of the plane thanks for getting a room
Jenna came back out of the room and hit
him in the head stop being a smartass
you finished the story that was Marlon
pin I was Marlon fan fiction Wow
like Wow come on that was a mate that
was absolutely amazing the plot twists
wrote that we can
yeah in the beginning I did yeah that
sorry it was on fire get a room
I love Howie like Marlon has these lines
where he's like in the stud of the
season to me chase Elliott chase Elliott
it was good it was really good sure
another or what Norma done I've wanted
to read I wanted to find the mature
content part of this one like I want to
see Stewart mmm let's get weird I'm just
looking for a second I was amazing
though I was so good I mean like know
this I guess that was a more fan fiction
fan fiction the other one was more of
like a yeah
a story story this one is more more me
being pregnant and peeing on a stick
again but that was lit [ __ ] go that
was dope I'm sorry but I will never be
able to look at your brother the same
way we got we got a joke I gotta tell ya
we should have him on the podcast yeah
why hasn't he been on the partner I
should put the podcast press one now
pink we should have Marlon on the
podcast
his name's ginger Tatum Channing
Channing ginger ginger ginger
ye and ginger um anyway uh yeah that was
fun I hope you enjoyed that and for
those E who stuck around I'm sorry we
didn't read it liked too much it's like
acting it out sort of her like more more
into it but like I you don't know where
it's going yeah it's hard but I think my
next job go and you I did feel around
like an being slow and dragging I felt
like we were reading lines like much
pretty fun every fun
do you like my Miranda impression its
dovey don't lie to me red lipstick
bitching going for my god you see like
losses who did you saw it was Marin
because I was seriously like oh my god
they wrote like a story about me eating
kidnapped by a girl with red lips and
then I see it's her Anna
yeah it's so amazing even another B um
well that you guys are hanging out with
us for another week let us know if you
want more than the podcast we will get
him on if you'd like that Marlin the
hacker only if he dresses like a hacker
that hacker how do you dress like a
hacker
I don't you just wouldn't be here he
needs a shirt that says hacker okay I'm
not a hacker not not a hacker guys check
out our sponsors go to blue apron comm
slash jenna julie and get to meals your
first two meals on us it's some of the
freshest ingredients you will ever have
and it's delivered right to your door
and go to club w.com slash jenna and
Julianne to get 20 bucks off your first
order right now thank you to our
sponsors guys make sure you go check
them out make a show free sure you guys
we appreciate you and we will see you
guys next week to talk about more Jenna
doing things not fanfiction again at
least in a row well we did really two
different weeks of two different things
that we don't usually do which is really
exciting that's true that's true we did
a smile I try new things too it's fun
this book I'm gonna go watch house of
cards alright you guys have a great have
a great day
[Music]
[Music]
you